combustible is finally being brought
back to the Disney Channel world this
February of 2019 except this time it's
in the form of a live-action movie
this comes as no surprise since the
animated version was such a hit for kids
everywhere after a more recent post
Sierra's posted a picture of herself
dressed as her character Athena she
tells us in her caption that this is her
first official look in the Disney
live-action movie some fans were quick
to point out that the outfit was very
similar to kim season four outfit and
they aren't wrong check out the outfit
side-by-side did he did a pretty good
job and it's kind of nice to see them
incorporating a lot of the details from
the original movie so there are
definitely a ton of details that Disney
has chosen to keep in the new movie
except this time a whole new cast for us
to know and love let's start off with
Sadie Stanley who will be playing Kim
Possible unlike so many other shows
where high school students are played by
actors in their 20s and sometimes even
late twenties and I'm looking at you
Riverdale Disney has actually chosen to
stay true to the original show by
casting Sadie Stanley it was only 17
years old to play high school student
Kim Possible way no not you later I
think I'll keep you around
Sadie is originally from Columbia South
Carolina and has started her acting
career at the age of just 13 years old
according to IMDB page her parents never
really took her love for acting too
seriously until she convinced them with
some classic old nagging it looks like
that was a solid move on Sadie's part
because it was not long after that she
landed her role on Disney and that is a
definite dream for every actor another
essential member of the new cast is Sean
Jane brownie who will be playing Ron
stoppable just one look at Sean and we
can already tell that he will be perfect
for the new role his Instagram is
already full of a ton of sweet and
quirky moments giving us that goofy Ron
stoppable vibe as far as his where it
goes he's got a ton of experience in
comedy and animation he started on ABC's
comedy series the Goldbergs
and on Cartoon Network's animated series
Clarence he even voices Richardson mol
from Disney XD's big hero six series and
a boy from Ralph breaks the Internet
those are some pretty big
accomplishments for someone who's only
19 years old and last but not least
let's talk about istick Bryan Brown who
will be voicing Kim's tech-savvy
accomplice wave load not you guys will
definitely recognize Isaac from his time
on America's Got Talent
he was only 6 years old when he got up
on that day
to sing dance and melt hearts everywhere
while he didn't end up winning the
competition he can't be too sad about it
now that he's developed an amazing
acting career he went on to play Raven
Baxter son in Disney's Ravens home
series and just like his fellow co-star
Shaun has plenty of experience in the
animated movie industry hmm Ronna a
no-show on a three for one shimmery
dough day for a little recap on the
character wait is a ten-year-old college
graduate who is famous for the stitch
that he always gets Kim and Ron he is
also responsible for all of Kim's
gadgets and transportation making it
essential to all her missions but you
rock Waller on the other hand it's going
to be played by these stunning Erika Tam
who even looks just like her character
well we know for sure is that just like
their characters these two ladies are
bound to be bad as hell and bring so
much for your sins to the show now one
of the issues that the entire internet
seems to be torn over is surprisingly
Kim's outfit in the original show we see
Kim and her staple khaki pants and her
blocked her and that crop top that she
probably bought from club banana in the
new shows trailer we see that the team
has chosen to switch things up a little
by giving Kim notably shorter sleeves
tighter pants and a no longer crop top
this was apparently enough to send fans
of the original show right over the edge
even demanding that they bring back
Kim's signature baggy pants but not
everyone has a problem with the new look
and apparently not even Kim Possible
herself Kristi Romano who voices Kim in
the original gave her a special stamp of
approval even tweeting that she is
totally freaking out about the new look
now I want to know if you guys are
feeling Kim's new outfit are all these
things just minor details that we
shouldn't really be paying attention to
I haven't quite made up my mind yet so
I'm gonna need you guys to help me out
on the lighter note though bus with Nina
Mohan has tweeted something hilariously
relatable she tweeted that even the
live-action can possible has fallen
victim to the eternal curse of womanhood
pants with no pockets there is no doubt
that we love the possible family before
but something tells me that we are going
to love them even more in the newer
movie Kim's mother doctor and possible
is going to be played by How I Met Your
mother's Alyson Hannigan Finnegan also
appeared in the classic TV series Buffy
the Vampire Slayer
Kim's grandmother played by actress
Connie Rey is also worth the mention she
is definitely worth the mention since
the trailer ends with a hardcore scene
of the ladies and
of course ready to kick some butt with
on-screen display of some awesome girl
power not for the question on everyone's
minds where it is our favorite naked
mole-rat Rufus will he even be
acknowledged in the storyline at all the
answer to that question is absolutely
hay is for horses young man and don't
stand up straight you'll push the truth
according to IMDB the movie's plot reads
everyday teen hero Kim Possible played
by Sadie Stanley and her best friend Ron
stoppable played by Sean Jam brony
embark on their freshman year of high
school all while saving the world from
evil villains while Kim and Ron have
always been one step ahead of their
opponents navigating the social
hierarchy of high school is more
challenging than these action heroes
ever imagined with dragon and cheetah
lurking in the wings Kim must rely on
her family and friends and team possible
Ron tech genius Wade new friend Athena
and Rufus a naked mole-rat to stop these
super villains that's right guys if
their sources are correct then Rufus
will definitely be back in making an
appearance now there's just one problem
have you guys ever seen a real naked
mole rat now let me tell you they aren't
nearly as cute as Rufus was so I wonder
how does he's gonna pull that one off
not gonna lie I am pretty excited to
find out before the end of our video and
then asking you guys to do some
investigative work for me real fans of
the original show have already noticed
that Monique Kim's best friend is
nowhere to be found in the show's cameo
do you guys think she'll be making an
appearance or has Disney actually just
replaced her altogether with character
Athena now don't get me wrong I would
totally love to see Monique's fabulous
character come to life but Disney did a
great job divers find their cast this
time around either way be sure to let me
know what you think of the upcoming
movie and any other opinions you might
have in the comments section below
as always thank you guys for watching
and I hope you enjoyed the video if you
did be sure to spread the things love in
the comment and community sections it's
your own or and I'll see you in our next
video
[Music]